are they degrees in heaven how many of you have
degrees of some kind can i see your hands you
got a masters and bachelor's associates all
right hands down i have a couple of them and i
paid for them so they're mine are they degrees
in heaven now the subject is extremely serious
and i must be able to depend on your maturity
to take it right between the eyes can i do that
all right in the book of uh matthew chapter
10 reading verse 37 and i'll let you out of
10 minutes to one for those of you who are here
for the first time and i will say more on the
subject this evening when i have a little
more time matthew chapter 10 reading verse
37 jesus is speaking and he says he that loveth
father and mother more than me is not worthy
of me and he that loveth son or daughter
more than me is not worthy of me
jesus being god clearly is calling for us to love
him to love the father to love god father son holy
ghost more than we love anyone else there must be
a clear and a sharp distinction between our love
horizontally and our love vertically now each
expression of love must be pure but one must be
more intense than the other our love for god must
be unmistakably greater than our love for friends
family yea spouses that's jesus not me saying
that now the wording of this same statement in
the book of luke is even more severe let's go to
luke chapter 14 reading verse 26 as we continue
are the degrees in heaven luke
chapter 14 reading verse 26.
luke says if any man come to me and love not
and hate he says father mother wife children
brethren sisters yea his own life also he is not
or he cannot be my disciple let me read that again
if any man comes to jesus and does not hate
father mother wife children brethren sisters
yea his own life also he cannot be my disciple
now the word hate must not be misunderstood
it simply means love less but i suspect luke
uses the word hate to knock us between the
eyes that we may wake up and understand that
jesus wants there to be no confusion we must
love god more than we love anyone else hands
down no controversy no contest no competition
so they are in that sense degrees yes
in heaven i'm not talking about academic
degrees i mean degrees of affection god
wants our highest degree of love now
there are degrees in the punishment of sinners
in luke chapter 12 reading from verse 44 christ
is giving a parable of the unfaithful servant
who because his lord has delayed his coming
becomes irresponsible the bible says but and if
that servant say in his heart my lord delayeth his
coming and shall begin to beat the men's servants
and the maidens and to eat and drink and be
drunkard the lord of that servant will come in an
hour when in a day when he looketh not for him and
at an hour when he is not aware and will cut him
asunder and will appoint him his portion with the
unbelievers next verse says and that servant which
knew his lord's will and prepared not himself
neither did according to his will
shall be beaten with how many stripes
many stripes next verse but he that which knew not
but did commit things worthy of stripes shall be
beaten with how many stripes few stripes now
stripes there refers to the final punishment
god is saying jesus is saying in the judgment
when people are punished some will
be punished more severely than others
now all sinners will be destroyed that's common
to all but the degree of suffering before you
finally vanquished off the face of the earth
will vary from person to person depending on
the degree of sinfulness of our lives well not
our lives the sinner's lives let's say we're
all god's people the bible says in revelation
22 12 behold i come quickly and my what reward
the wages of sin is death but what comes
with eternal life a gift there is a gift
which is eternal life for all who are saved
but then there is something called the reward
all saved people receive the gift same gift which
is we're saved remember the parable jesus told the
man went into the marketplace looking for workers
he went early in the morning he said one penny
he went two hours later one penny he went a few
hours later one penny he went the eleventh hour
one penny same gift salvation but the rewards
we enjoy in the new world varies from person to
person based on our degree of faithfulness on this
earth now i won't i don't have time to go into
that i need to stress that the bible teaches every
man and woman is record is rewarded individually
and the reward is different from the gift the
gift i say is salvation the reward refers to
all the print all the the privileges that come
with living in heaven they will vary from person
to person based on how faithful we have been
down here of course my favorite writer ellen
white says whatever our reward is everyone will
be satisfied and happy there are degrees in heaven
two nights ago we read about evil spirits in uh
luke chapter 11 i think it is verses 24 to 26
when the unclean spirit is gone out of a man he
walketh through dry places looking for rest and
findeth none he saith i will return unto my house
once i came out and when he cometh he findeth
it swept and garnished then goeth he and taketh
to himself seven other spirits more wicked than
himself there are degrees of wickedness among
the inhabitants of the kingdoms of darkness
that's biblical teaching now let's go back to
our original introduction god desires there to be
degrees in the amount of love we show between him
and between our fellow men we must love him more
now in mark chapter 12 reading from
verse 28 is now 22 minutes after 12.
we have about 28 minutes left i believe
mark chapter 12 reading from verse 28
and one of the scribes came and having heard them
reasoning together and perceiving
that he had answered them well
asked him which is the first commandment of
all what he means by first is the foremost
that's the question the scribe is asking jesus
jesus responds immediately the first of all the
commandments or the foremost is hear o israel the
lord our god is one lord and thou shalt love the
lord with all thy heart and with all thy soul
and with all thy mind and with all thy strength
and the second commandment is like namely this
thou shall love thy neighbor as thyself jesus
says the foremost love god with all your heart and
soul and mind and strength and the second one is
love your neighbor as yourself this is consistent
with what jesus says in matthew matthew luke 14
26 if you come to me you've got to love me more
than father mother wife children brothers sisters
more than your very own life now in matthew
22 from verse 34 to 40 we have the similar
situation being reported by matthew and verse 36
the scribe said which is the first commandment
in the law or the greatest commandment in the
law jesus said to him the first commandment is
thou shalt love the lord with all thy heart
with all thy soul with all thy mind this is
the first and great commandment that's what jesus
said that verse 38 matthew 22 this is the first
and great commandment and the second is
like unto it thou shalt love thy neighbor
as thyself he said on these hang all the
law and the prophets meaning every other
precept and judgment that we read in the bible
find their meaning in the context of loved god
love to fellow men meaning the ten commandments
follow me closely are their degrees in heaven
when the bible says thou shalt love the lord
with all thy heart and soul and mind and might
and strength and understanding is referring
to the first four commandments on one table
of the law love thy neighbor as thyself refers
to the other six because the ten commandments
are divided into two love for god love for your
fellow man no bible teacher worth his or her salt
has any problem with that love for god love for
mankind now we may not we need not feel badly
if god says love me more because the more i love
god the better of you will be are you following me
so god has people in mind when he tells
people love me more because the more i
love god the more i'll respect you and i'll
demonstrate my love to god by how i treat you
so there isn't a clean break between the first
four and last six yet jesus wants there to be
a clear demonstration of our greater love for
him than for one another so that if my mother
tells me stop going to church on sabbath i say
mom i love you with all my heart i'll die for
you now i'll give you both kidneys if you need
them now or both livers however many we have
but i must obey god first are you listening
to me when the mother of jesus found him in
the temple luke chapter 2 verse 48 to 50. she
said thy father and i have sought this soaring
why hast thou thus dealt with us what are you
doing to us jesus said why are you looking for me
how is it that you sought me
whiskey not that i must be what
about my father's business he said that to his
earthly mother in other words my father's business
comes ahead of your business yet the chapter
ends by saying he went down to nazareth and was
subject unto them no disrespect let me stress
it again we must love god more than people
and our love for god is expressed in
thou shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any graven image
thou shalt not take the name of the lord thy
god in vain and remember the sabbath day to keep
it holy that's love to god we know the other six
now i told you i want to have courage
and take this right between the eye
most people worship on sunday am i right yes i am
why is that don't answer me just think why is that
okay we'll allow a couple of seconds
to have that phone put to death
why is it that most people worship on sunday
well somewhere in history an attempt was made
to change god's law and i said an attempt
because to change god's law you have to go
to heaven and change the original what was
in the ark in the wilderness that was a copy
copies are have only limited value you know that
if you want to sell your house
you better get the original deed
no copy you want god's law changed you've
got to make the change on the original now
but an attempt was made and many people
follow that attempt and throughout history
the power uh accredited with having made
that change is the people power located in
the vatican and that has been said numerous
times by scholars of that church that they
claim the right the church claimed the right to
make that change the catholic church fine and
they regard it as a par a mark a demonstration
of the power of the church to decide which day
is holy and which day is not by changing a law
that god himself made now here is the critical
and the serious implication of changing god's law
now follow me closely because of those changes
made by the papal system there are two versions of
the ten commandments listen to me carefully 12 28.
is there a camera following me you know so i can
move this and i can come down is it okay all right
this is long enough stay right about
here in the bible exodus 20 deuteronomy
5. the first commandment is let's put it on my
right side the side of power the side of victory
thou shalt have no other gods before me the change
version says the same thing thou shalt have know
the gods before me in the ten commandments
in the bible the second one says thou shalt
not make unto thee any grievan image nor the
likeness of anything that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath or that is in
the water under the earth thou shalt not bow
down thyself to them nor serve them for i the lord
thy god i'm a jealous god visiting the iniquity of
the fathers upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me and showing
mercy unto thousands of them that love me and
keep my commandments and i need to see that clock
that's in the version in the bible in this change
version that commandment does not appear it's gone
so number two on this version is thou shalt
not take the name of the lord thy god in vain
in the bible's version number three is thou shalt
in the changed version number three is
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
in the bible's version number four is remember the
sabbath day to keep it holy six days shalt thou
label unto all thy work but the seventh day is
the sabbath of the lord thy god and it thou shalt
not do any work thou not i son nor thy daughter
that my servant not my maidservant not a cattle
nor thy stranger that is within thy gates for in
six days the lord made heaven on earth the sea and
all that in them is and rested the seventh
day wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day and hallowed it over here the changed
version commandment for is honor thy father
and thy mother now skip all the way to number
10 over here number 10 is thou shalt not covet
thy neighbor's house that shall not cover the
neighbor's wife now he's ox no his ass no he's
man servant now he's made servant now anything
that is thy neighbors over here number 10 is
taken from here and split into two and made into
nine and ten and that's necessary because 2 was
taken out from the side are you following me so
mathematically we have 10 in the change version
we have 10 in the original version but the
10 over here differ from the 10 over there
because number two here is not number two there
number two over here is vanished from num from
this version over here so this is the catholic
version not found in the catholic bible but in
the catechism because a catholic instructs
you from the catechism not from the bible
am i being fair so far all right now what
is the big thing about the changes over here
here's the change here's the
big thing what did jesus say
is the first and great commandment
love god more than whom
father mother wife children brothers sisters
or your own life luke 14 26 matthew 10 37 he
that loveth father mother more than me is not
worthy of me he that loveth son or daughter more
than me is not worthy of me and jesus said the
first and great commandment is thou shalt love
the lord with all thy heart and soul and mind
and that is just a summary of the first four
now if you look at the man-made version as it
appears in the catechism of the catholic church
the first four commandments in their decalogue
which are reserved which express love for god
alone that commandment includes a human being
are you listening to me because
in their version number four says
what honor thy father and thy mother
so jesus he could not say thou shalt love the lord
with all thy heart and soul and might and mind
he'd have to change the arrangement of the
division of the decalogue because now there is
a human being in the side that's assigned only
to god and christ is clear you must love god
more than you love human beings but there's now a
human being introduced in the first four honor thy
father thy mother now the bible says in matthew
23 verse 9 and call no man father upon earth now
christ means spiritually because in the parable
of the prodigal son he said a certain man had
two sons and the younger son said unto his father
so jesus understands blood relationships he means
spiritually you have one father matthew 23 verse
nine for the for you have one father which is in
heaven now what's one of the names of the pope the
what the holy father listen to john 17 11 jesus
christ is praying and now i'm no more in the world
and these are in the world and i come to thee
holy father keep through thy no name those whom
thou has given me that they may be one as we are
we have two holy fathers the one jesus
prayed to and the one who sits in the vatican
he is as people call him and i'm using this
as a historical reference the holy father
in that context jesus says matthew 23 9
do not call anyone on this earth father
spiritually speaking now so in this version we
have a human being now if jesus were to say love
god more than you love people with this version
that has been changed what we have there is that
this father here is receiving a devotion and a
love and affection that only belongs to whom god
and any man who receives a
devotion that only belongs to god
must consider himself to be what god
i don't believe i made it
clear did i make it clear
in this version we have a man
who is we have a a man not of god
who is a god we have a man who needs
to be saved from sin who is a god
and now the commandments read in that version
thou shalt love the lord thy god with all thy
heart and that includes a human being listen
to me this is more serious than we think
catholic writers have written
that the pope is god on earth
i'm not beating any church i'm not doing
that i really not in the presence of god i
say from my heart i am not beating up on the
church i'm trying to say what is historical
if i say there was a holocaust in world
war ii do i have anything against germans
no if i say the u.s invaded afghanistan and iraq
do i have something against my own country no if
i say the japanese born pearl harbin december
7 1941 do i have something against japan no
if i say jesus cast up the devil long time ago
do i have something against the devil yes yes
great prejudice yes but that's an exception
oh yes i don't like him and so what i'm
saying to you from my heart as your brother
and i have a moral responsibility and god
expects me to bring this to your attention
it is not a light matter that an attempt
has been made to change god's law
and the change was made in a place where a man
is now receiving what only god should receive
a man is now part of the first and
great commandment it is no wonder
that this man is regarded as being infallible
when he speaks ex cathedra or from his throne
now did i say yesterday before that when god
set up the ark of the covenant he said put
the mercy seat right above the ark and
i and i will meet with thee from here
this is where i will speak god said exodus
25 22 and from here i will meet with thee
and i will commune with thee from above the
mercy seat from between the two cherubims
which are upon the ark of the testimony of all
things which i will give thee in commandment
unto the children of israel god says when i
speak i will speak ex cathedra from my throne
the catholic church says when the pope speaks
ex-cathedra he is infallible ex-cathedral
means he's not taking a shower and then he
says something when he's fully robbed and
he's officially speaking he is infallible
ex-cathedral for him ex-cathedral for god
and our minds have to be clear
and our understanding sharp
revelation issues a very
serious warning revelation 22 18
but i testify unto every man who heard
the words of the prophecy of this book
if any man will add on to this
god shall add unto him the plagues
that are written therein and if any man will take
away from the words of the book of this prophecy
god shall take away his part out of the book of
life and from the holy city and from the things
which are written in this book meaning this book
i have told you the law of god is the expression
of his sacredness his holiness his
righteousness his character i have
told you the law of god is the very constitution
on which the kingdom of god functions throughout
the unfenced expats of the universe i've
told you the law of god is the constitution
that should operate on this earth because the
kingdom of god in you and in me represents an
extension of that heavenly kingdom with the same
constitution but the constitution has been changed
and so the second commandment has
been removed not modified removed
and the power that removed it is represented
on the first table of the deck log which
represents absolute devotion to god
and that power is personified in
the pope i say personified if he
passes away someone takes his place same
thing so it is a system more than a person
are you following me people just come and fit into
the system u.s democracy is a system george bush
goes someone takes experience then he goes someone
takes his place you fit into the system and it is
a system that places a man where god ought to be
and that place is a man where he ought not to be
the last person the last created being
who tried that was cast down to hell
isaiah 14 13 and 14 for thou has said in thine
heart i will ascend into heaven i will exalt
my throne above the stars of god the stars of god
being more than just the stars that shine it means
all the created beings that's why at creation
the sons of god and the stars shouted to get
the morning stars trying signed together the sons
of god shouted i will sit also upon the mount of
the congregation in the size of the north i will
ascend above the heights of the clouds i will be
like the most high that was lucifer's desire with
all due respect that is what has been attempted
and millions of people not realizing it
are giving a devotion to a human being
that belongs only to god now
of all the ten commandments
if i can use the word violent the
most violent is commandment two
listen to one it's uh i have nine minutes this is
the commandment one thou shalt have another gods
before me is that violent no that's plain simple
commandment three thou shalt not take the name of
the lord thy god in vain for the lord will not
hold him guiltless that taketh his name in vain
there is some little threat in there but not very
obvious commandment four remember the sabbath fine
commandment five uh honor i found thy mother fine
six thou shalt not kill that's not violent that's
peace don't kill seven thou shalt commit adultery
eight that shall not steal nine don't be false
witness then don't covet but listen to two thou
shalt not make unto thee any graven image nor the
likeness of anything that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath or that is in
the water under the earth thou shalt not bow down
thyself to them nor serve them for i the lord thy
god i'm a what jealous god visiting the iniquity
of the father what does he mean by visiting
pouring it out on them visiting the iniquity
of the fathers upon the children and to the
third and fourth generation of them that
hate me i'm gonna pass it down the line
why if you worship any other person beside me
and that's the commandment that was taken out
for two reasons well one major reason in
the papal system the roman church images
are worshiped i used to worship them
because i used to be an acolyte with
great pride serving next to the priest as a
little boy i pray to them i kiss their feet
but god called me out of darkness into
his marvelous light now i kiss the feet
of jesus with great joy and that foot is
warm there's blood in it that he shed for me
but the church had to remove that commandment in
order to permit the worship of images now before
we sit back smug and say we don't do that yes we
do some people set aside god in order to get a man
some men set aside god in order to get a woman
no difference you think an idol has to
be stone and wooden the idol is simply
that which comes before god some people set
aside god because of a career opportunity
same idol worship so don't go jumping on
the catholics let's jump on one another
some people set aside god to get a
degree i'm gonna study on sabbath
the exam comes on sabbath i've spent all
these thousands of dollars in intuition
i might not take the exam on sabbath no
you're not supposed to well i'll take it and
then say i'm sorry put in an exam a head of god
worshiping an idol removing the second commandment
in order to do whatever it is you and i want
to do same difference as we say 12 44 6 minutes
the subject is so serious you notice i haven't
shouted at you once i shout every other night
i didn't feel the urge to shout i felt you
would be reasonable and you would just listen
god's commandments are not to be changed
the second was removed in the
catholic catechism it doesn't appear
in order that idols may be worshipped
the fourth one in god's version
was kept with modification which
means it is not the commandment at all
now it is number three the catholic version
which says remember the sabbath and keep it
holy and that's where it ends it doesn't say six
days shall thou labor that's really where it ends
you keep the sabbath yes but
you keep the one the church made
not the one god made and so by
keeping that sabbath which is sunday
you're still worshiping idols because
you're putting someone else ahead of god
how many of you how many of us
accept the words of jesus if
any man love father and mother
more than me he is not worthy of me
do you accept that into your heart
christ must come first
when you and i say the first commandment is
thou shalt love the lord with all thy heart
with all thy soul with all thy mind and with all
thy strength we must not have the pope in mind
or the gc president or the dalai lama
or whomever shiva zoroaster quetzalcoatl we
must not have these people we must have only god
who created heaven and earth and we must be
sure because the devil's deception are so subtle
he will have you worshipping a man
and you don't even know don't even
know because that is what has happened with
the change of the ten the first decalogue
that applies to god as far as expression of
love in that corrupted version a man is involved
and so if you say that based upon that
version you're simply saying i love that man
as much as i love god that is a tremendous
insult to god and he cannot let it pass by
i believe you're listening
with your heart and your head
i have three minutes come back tonight i'll
say more invite some friends this is very
very serious and i have one simple appeal for
you you've got to get back to work in the classes
how many of you will say lord my
eyes have been opened by your grace
by the power of jesus christ give me the spiritual
courage to worship you alone stand your feet
you and you alone
every head bowed every eye closed loving
father in heaven we bow in this quiet hour
to thank you that you're always eager to open our
eyes father the deceptions of the devil are so
sophisticated that for many people it is too late
before they recognize it but for us in mercy you
have sent us a message that has opened our eyes
we must love you more than we love anyone else
and that love is expressing the first four
commandments which does not include a human being
except the god man christ who is more of man
and god lord if we in any way have put anything
or anyone ahead of you relationships education
career we apologize from our hearts because we
do not want the judgment to be brought upon us and
our children expressed in the second commandment
forgive us father because that is your nature
grant us the spirit of obedience that jesus had
now take us to our responsibilities of the
consciousness that we must work in such a way
that demonstrates we love you so much we will work
faithfully grant us traveling mercies and bring
us back tonight at the appointed place i offer
this prayer in jesus name and for his sake and
all god's people say amen and amen god bless you
it's 12 49 travel safely we shall see you tonight
you